δεν μου την ετάλλων περιθόρειο παράνακινηθούμε ε την νομικίνο οδώ που πιστεύωότα όταν έκαμα το
πρώτον έτοιμα για τ έχει μεγάλε σημασιάν το δύο για σικοστρία παραίθεση ο τελευταίος σύλλογος
τακτικό μέρος της όμος ποντίας ήταν πριείναι κατόνα έξι χρόνια το χίλια νιακόσα δεκαηνια ήταν
ο τελευταίο σύλλογος που τηνμουργήθηκε ο αλ γυναστικός λογος πράξανδρος καταλαβαίνεις τώρα πριν εκατόν έξι
χρόνια πάεγώ να κάμω ύλλογο εναι που πάει σαςσουμε ναι όμως ένατακραθέρουμε είμαι σίγουρ να
τα καταφέρω γιατί δεν πάω να κάμου κάτι παράνουμε να κάμω κάτι το οποιον θέλουν
να βοηθσω κατι νόμημο και το δύο για σίκο στρι όταν έκαμαν το ατοημα σκεφανταστείται
ένα παλαιωμένων καταστατηκών της όμς οντίας το οποίο δεν είχε καν κανονισμούς και αναγκάσαμε όταν
επίνιαίτηση ιδική μας ότι η κύρι θέλουμε να γίουμε τακτικό μέοι όμος ποντίας ο εβδομος
σύλλογος οι οκτο μήνες διάρκησε γιατί αναγκαστικαν να κάμουση κανονισμούς στο καταστατικών που υπήρχε που
είχε νιομοσποντήσί αυτά να και κάποια προβλέμα που ως επιληθούν αν δημιοργηθεί πλέννε καινον τα
έχκαθλισμού που θα πούν όλα υποτιο πρέλθέλω να καταλήξει ότι κάνοντας τον την κίνηση θεωρώ
ότε βοήθησα την κατάσταση να γίείναι ένα σωστών καταστατικό νι όμως πουντία να υπάρχουν κανονισμί
καιτώρα δεν ξέρω ότι για να μημεπαντούν προφανος κάτι άλλο συμβαίνει περιμένω όμως θα έχω
αλην ακόμα υπόμονή όμως από σας είπα με την ομάδαμο θα κινηθούμε ετηνομικήοδών υπάρχει αδέα
υπάρχει οκό επάρχου το κράτος ακούσευν έχει ανότι θέλουν να ξι χρονισούν θέλουν να αλλάξους
θέλουν να δημιουργήσουν νέα πράγματα αι καιρώσει είναι θαμε είμαστε να βοηθήσουμε και γιατί όχι
να μη γίείναι ένα σεβδόμος σύλλογος νομέρις όται όχι ανάγκη οτςο τόπος μας